Machine knitting a sweater
should be easy, right?
Just cast on, throw some yarn
at the machine, and let it do its thing.
And voila, you have the perfect sweater.
If only it worked that way.
Too many knitters believe myths that lead
to frustrations and wasted time,
like thinking the machine does all
the work or that any yarn will
magically knit up beautifully.
And let's not even talk
about skipping swatching.
I see so many knitters running before they
can walk, diving into knitting a sweater
without building the right skills first.
And that's when things
start to unravel, literally.
But don't worry, if this sounds
familiar, you're not alone.
At Knitted Now, we help machine knitters
like you build confidence,
master techniques,
and avoid these mistakes with our
step-by-step success path,
skill builders, and all of our tutorials.
And to make sure you start off
on the right foot,
I've put together
a Sweater Planning Worksheet,
a handy printable guide that walks you
through all the important decisions
before you start knitting.
Grab your copy for free using
the link in the description.
So let's dive into myths and mistakes.
Let's start with the biggest myth.
The machine does all the work.
Well, wouldn't that be nice?
But in reality, your machine is only
as good as the knitter using it.
You control the knitting stitches.
You control the garment assembly.
Think of it like cooking.
Having a fancy-dancy kitchen doesn't
automatically make you a great chef.
It knit It Now, we teach you how to take
control of your machine so you're the one
in charge, not just hoping for the best.
Another common myth that any yarn
will work on any knitting machine.
Have you ever your head stitches drop,
yarn gets stuck, or your machine
just refused to knit smoothly?
Chances are you are using the wrong yarn.
Each machine has a specific gage range,
and some fibers just don't work
well with certain machines.
That's why it's crucial to check your
machine specifications,
and most importantly, swatch before
committing to a full sweater.
Speaking of swatching, Swatching.
Let's talk about one of the biggest
mistakes I see: skipping it altogether.
Now, I get it.
You're anxious to jump in and get netting.
Skipping your swatch is like hanging
a picture without measuring first.
You might get lucky,
but more often than not, it ends up
crooked, off-center, or just plain wrong.
Taking a few extra minutes to swatch is
like using a level and a measuring tape.
It ensures everything lined lines
up perfectly before you commit.
Your swatch tells you everything: gage,
fabric drape, and potential yarn issues.
Without it, you're just guessing.
And trust me, guessing doesn't
lead to good fitting sweaters.
At Knit It Now, it isn't just encouraged,
it's a crucial step in our
sweater knitting process.
That's why we introduce the
Get Acquainted Swatch in our classroom.
Available available exclusively
to members, this guided exercise walks you
through swatching the right way,
helping you understand your machine, yarn,
and tension before you even
cast on for a full project.
No more Passwork, just reliable results.
Are you serious about knitting
sweaters that you'd love to wear?
Make sure you check out the get-acquainted
swatch technique in our classroom.
The link is in the description.
Next up, a mistake of diving
into a pattern without reading it first.
Patterns are like roadmaps.
If you don't check where you're going,
you might end up lost.
Before casting on, take a few minutes
to read through the whole pattern.
Highlight key instructions and make sure
you understand all
the techniques involved.
This simple habit will save you hours
of frustration and help
you knit with confidence.
And finally, let's talk
about finishing techniques.
A beautifully knit sweater can still look
homemade if the seams are bulky,
the neckline is uneven,
or the hems aren't finished right.
Taking the time to seam neatly C,
block your pieces, and add details makes
all of the difference between,
I made this, and, Wait, you made this?
If finishing techniques intimidate you,
we've got a full library of tutorials
Inside Knitted Now to walk
you through every step.
Now, if you've been nodding along
realizing you've made some of these
mistakes, don't worry,
you're in great company.
More importantly, we've got you covered.
At Knit It Now, we make machine knitting
easier with our success path,
a library of tutorials,
our skill builders,
and our customizable patterns.
Plus, we have a supported a supported
community of like-minded machine knitters.
By busting these myths and avoiding these
mistakes, you're already on the path
to sweater knitting success.
But we're just getting started.
In the next video,
we'll cover advanced techniques to take
your sweaters from good to amazing.
Don't miss it.
Thanks for watching.
And don't forget to grab your
Sweater Planning worksheet below.
We'll see you in the next
video and happy knitting.